[Music]
hello there this is an interview with
the authors of the paper learning what
you don't know by virtual outlier
synthesis this paper presents a method
to create what it calls virtual outliers
which are synthetic out of distribution
data points in the latent space of the
model and then it trains that model to
successfully recognize these points as
out of distribution the paper performs
very well on a wide variety of
benchmarks and i have actually made a
comprehensive paper review in the last
video about this paper if you haven't
checked that out please do because i'll
go over the paper i'll explain
everything that's in it and the authors
that i'm interviewing today have seen
that review so we all start from a
common level and they're directly able
to respond to my criticisms which is
really really cool so in this interview
we go over a lot of topics but mainly i
get my questions answered and we get a
bit of a look at the behind the scenes
of the research how the research came
about what the authors were interested
in how they solved problems that came up
in between and much more i hope you like
these paper reviews plus interview
things let me know how i can improve
these videos for you by leaving a
comment like if you do like the video
subscribe or tell someone to subscribe
and i'll see you around bye bye
hi everyone today i'm here with sharon
lee and shifang do who are authors on
the virtual outlier synthesis paper and
uh are joining me today
uh discussing well the paper and as well
as my attempt at an explanation of it uh
sharon shifang welcome to the channel
thank you for having us
thank you
it's very cool to have you here um so
you have you've made this paper it has
gathered i think a fair bit of attention
in the community um
because outlier detection obviously is a
big big challenge uh especially for
security critical applications and not
only do you do outlier detection in
classification where we usually see it
but in like sort of the more challenging
task of of object detection so my my
first question would be how did you even
how did you come up with this because it
is not an obvious idea let's say uh to
even tackle this problem like what made
you
made you tackle the problem in the first
place yeah thank you for the question
i'd be happy to share i guess from a
little bit behind the scene on the
research
story how it
got started
and by the way we're really uh
encouraged
to see the
uh you know the interest from the the
community about uh our work
and so you know personally i really i am
driven to solve
problems that are real meaning that has
some connection to
the real world and just like you said i
think out of distribution detection is
one of those problems that
really matter a lot
in
deploying machine learning models in the
real world
and so you know sometimes when we're
getting closer to this
you know more realistic scenarios
that also means problems are getting
harder and more complex and this
actually takes a trajectory to
to get there um it's actually reflected
i think in how the field of you know ood
detection has evolved and unfolded over
the years and so if you look at
some of the early research you know
we've done including some other
researchers have done
in the space
um a very common you know way to
evaluate how good the algorithms are
are based on the uh benchmark um
which is you know now similarly uh seems
quite artificial like if you train a
model on cypher 10 and then you evaluate
against um data sets such as street view
housing number or svgn
and so the seemingly simple task
actually took a while for the research
community to make make progress on i
think over the years we've definitely
done
a much you know better job developing
algorithms to reduce the false positive
rate
and so that's why sort of you know we
think it's you know we're at a better
timing to
start tackling some of the harder
questions on the
object detection side and why object
detection is very interesting and
important because that directly has
a you know a better connection right for
example you think about self-driving
cars
none of those images are
simple as cipher 10 which has a single
object well centered around in the scene
right in the real world we are going to
encounter
inputs that have
multiple objects in the scene
and some of those are in distribution um
which mean they have been exposed to the
model during the training time and some
of those
uh are not quite um and so i was you
know really glad when kind of triple
joined the lab as well to start tackling
some of the
uh the questions so that's you know when
we started the project earlier um
actually last year already last last
spring semester that's when we started
so you you you were already in the space
of outlier detection let's say in the in
the broad space of solving these types
of problems and then um
you yeah how
what made you what made you decide
object detection that's it did you did
you run across a problem or is this just
a natural continuation of the
classification data sets ah that's
another great question so you know why
object detection uh so one of the
like you said i think one of the typical
you know scenario when we think about
where outlier detection or out of
distribution detection algorithms are
being used in the reward is some of the
high stake scenarios like safety
critical ones for example in
self-driving
and that um is kind of
built on these object detection models
where not only we have to perform
classification but at the same time
being able to
you know localize where the uh where the
objects are so i think in terms of
uh motivation that just seems like a
very natural
you know um application focus um to to
start with and of course um we have been
like you said we have been in this
uh the space for
working on the problem i think since a
couple years ago um and most of the work
we've done in the space are on image
classification and so in terms of
solution i also wanted to share a little
bit how we arrive at this virtual
outlier uh synthesis so you know i think
the first motivation is pretty
straightforward we wanted to kind of go
beyond
image level od detection to have this
finer grained uncertainty estimates
that tells us at the object level
whether things are in distribution or d
i think figure one in the paper is kind
of
a perfect illustration for
why we need object level uncertainty
right so as you
explained quite eloquently in your video
that you know this car
is something the model has observed
which is in distribution object right
whereas this moves here is something
that was not exposed to the model during
training and so this picture
kind of highlights the complexity that
an image can contain at the same time
both in distribution and od object and
therefore we can't just derive an image
level
you know uncertainty measurement we have
to you know go find our grain at the
object level and so
that was the first
you know first uh
i would say the higher level motivation
on the object detection side
uh and then on the solution side i want
to share a little bit ella
how we arrive at the virtual outlier uh
since so the idea the algorithmic
idea of this paper is largely inspired
by one of our
previous papers
uh on
energy-based ood detection which was
published at
nurbs in 2020 and so in that paper we
focused on
image classification setting um but from
a learning
algorithm perspective
we proposed this called energy
regularized learning which
in a nutshell is trying to oh i see your
cat there just walking by um so in a
nutshell that learning framework tries
to
kind of tackle the problem of
classification by not only minimizing
the risks on the
in distribution data set
but at the same time we're introducing a
regularizer and this regularizer has
very similar spirit as what we're using
here in this paper
and so this regularizer is trying to
kind of minimizing the um the risk or
trying to
pushing the energy surface to be as
distinguishable
between uh known distribution versus
unknown distribution and so for the
image classification setting
um we used this um
uh
so we called we use this technique or
data set of outlier exposure
which relies on an external uh different
data set right that's not overlapping
with the indistribution data set um so
that's what that's actually one of the
you know requirement or limitation if
you call in
in that learning framework um and that
does not directly translate into the
object detection setting anymore because
as you can imagine in order to
you know bring in a
outlier
data set for object detection it's going
to be tricky because you have to
annotate through
tons of images to make sure that at the
object level things do not overlap with
our training data and so this data
collection itself is a prohibitive
process
and it can be very time consuming um
and laborious and so on um
and so that also kind of motivate us to
think
well if is no external data we can rely
on is there any way we can devise
some of the outlier data
from the in distribution data
itself right so that's where this whole
idea started really is to to to think um
further how we improve
um on top of the original learning
learning framework that we had
and then and then and that's how you um
gathered the ideas of synthesizing
points that are uh not where where the
data is is there a connection to i'm not
sure how aware of
young lacan has been pushing this uh
energy-based learning a lot sort of
pushing energy up where data is pushing
energy down anywhere else do you see
some sort of a connection to that
absolutely and in fact the work that i
just mentioned on energy based out of
distribution detection that was
published at europe's 2020 was precisely
inspired by you know this whole energy
based
uh framework um
um from you know young lagun
by the way the the plural of moose is
moose i didn't know in my video
that's good to know
i i just i figured it out
not me
um
yeah so i mean it makes
it makes it makes sense and you've
you've seen my you've seen my
explanation right and i think one of the
one of the criticisms a bit that i had
was if everything's pretty in this sort
of 2d landscape where you know you can
show here's the data and you know
there's outside the data but it gets
it gets very complicated once you go to
to higher dimensions um you for example
you had you had uh
the picture here
when you mentioned you know we assume
that the high dimensional data are our
gaussians and um
you know how how now obviously your
method works right i think your
evaluation is very thorough you measure
on a lot of data sets against a lot of
baselines and so on right so obviously
something works here um however do you
do you have some maybe some response to
to me to someone who says
there's you know i don't
this does not convince me that a
gaussian mixture model is appropriate
for this really high dimensional data
yeah i actually like that question a lot
so you know one uh i wanted to maybe
take a step back and first just to
uh you know highlight
one of the key
i i guess the key insight and knowledge
which i like about this paper aside from
the the distributional assumption that
we made here
is the fact that
the virtual outlier senses is done in
the feature space right this as opposed
to the original high dimensional pixel
space
is already a much much lower
dimensionality right so what you see
here this
uh since this is completely done
uh in this later representation or
sometimes we extract this from the
penultimate layer
and of a neural network and so some
earlier works um
explored
so we're now the first to kind of try to
synthesize
our liars
but what we've done differently is to
realize
in order to regularize the neural
network's decision boundary we don't
have to go all the way right to the
original pixel space where
training again model can be you know
quite tricky and the convergence is um
is going to be a challenging problem on
its own so that's one kind of step
um which i think an important step that
we've taken is to look into
a
lower dimensional
space
which in some sense makes this problem
more tractable compared to the original
data space and now coming to the second
point i think when it comes to modeling
the
density of the representation space um
it's actually also a non-trivial problem
right density estimation on its own i
think i think it's a notoriously hard
problem in machine learning and so when
we initially approach this problem
we kind of make this um i would say you
know
gaussian mixture distribution is the
most
straightforward assumption kind of um
to make and this um
this first um algorithmic framework i
would say you know we kind of just
wanted to show
even under somewhat simplified um
assumption of
representation space being being
gaussian you can still do this virtual
outlier synthesis attractively
and train things end-to-end um and from
an empirical perspective as you said it
actually works
um surprisingly well um but that doesn't
mean this this has to be the only you
know solution to it i think there are
great opportunities that vos really
opens up to is
how do we you know um perform
this synthesis in the feature space more
creatively right
when it when it comes to the method
itself you have this overview diagram
right here and i've i've i've attempted
to explain this a little bit did you
find my explanation
satisfactory is there something missing
is there emphasis in the wrong place or
or what would you what would you add to
um so people really understand what's
going on
i think you did a phenomenal job
explaining this whole pipeline perhaps
you know in a clear way if we were have
to present
ourselves um one thing i
wanted to maybe call out um is this
notion of
um
you know this uncertainty loss why we
formulate this
problem um that way um so you know at a
higher level you can think of
our learning framework
it's trying to do something
more than the typical supervised you
know um surprise learning um say
training a model based on cross entropy
loss
there's a bit of element um in the
census part which closer to this
generative modeling and density
estimation which we've also talked about
and so the whole framework combines
sort of you know both bits of uh
supervised learning and also you know
there is some
dusty estimation
involved
as well i think one interesting bits in
the learning methodology is how we
leverage energy
as an uncertainty measurement
and to separate apart the um the known
objects versus the um the unknown ones
um and so it's somewhat a
problem that's not quite
um
not quite as complex as trying to you
know estimate exactly the point wise
density you know p of x
but rather we're kind of picking backing
on as a
simpler problem of
we just want this
energy
to be
estimated as a level set that is
sufficient enough to separate these two
parts of data rather than getting every
single point
estimated correctly if that makes sense
yeah the the uncertainty loss you
describe it
somewhere
and yeah so
i think i had this this this other
comment where
um i said directly this loss sort of
only affects sort of the classification
layer however you know if when you think
about it what you could do is you could
simply take your gaussian mixture model
right and you could simply
have your your data point there and you
could say well if it's unlikely it's out
of distribution right i could simply map
my inference data point and then
evaluate it according to the gaussian
mixture model that i have at training
time and i say well it's low likelihood
it's out of distribution gone right i
wouldn't need all of this thing which
tells me that this loss does more than
just you know modify the last layer but
so there is a
almost is it fair just or
is this correct my assumption that there
is like this downstream effect
um on the entire model
how would you
like intuitively adding a loss like this
what does it do to the whole
you know the whole feature extraction
pipeline that leads to the that leads to
the
latent space
yeah that's a great question so perhaps
to um
you know answer a bit more to that on if
do you mind screwing up a little bit i
think we have
uh perfect yes that posterior
probability right there so keep in mind
this whole training
is done in an end-to-end fashion right
and then whenever we have an input
object that goes into this network
we are
optimizing for this loss and this loss
will be back propagated all the way
right through this entire
convolutional backbone in this object
detector
and so this objective
uncertainty is trying to
kind of separate apart um in terms of
this energy we'll get to this
interpretation of the energy later on
but at the very
high level it's trying to just push
energy to be two sides one is above zero
one is below zero right and if we look
at this connection with respect to this
posterior probability here so we can
interpret energy
as
um
as this uh you know
as this uh density function for that
data point p of x
um perhaps plugged in with some unknown
factor that we don't know right and so
this energy does not precisely capture
this density just yet but during this
optimization process we hope
that through this propagation and
minimizing this objective
that this whole training would converge
to a point
where
the density um could be more separable
between the id object and then over the
object and so that's the inherent
connection between you know the
uncertainty measurement to the the
density so you sort of want
maybe reformulate it a bit you want to
to coerce the feature extractor almost
to to give you a space where you can be
more certain about in distribution data
but then like
the the less certain about out of
distribution data um exactly so this is
is naturally naturally it is a harder
problem right if you go back to this
even in the two-dimensional the
two-dimensional case i i mentioned this
is like to separate three classes i need
three lines right but to separate three
you know clusters of data from their
surroundings i need like a a very
you know
decision boundary that's shaped you know
highly complex high dimensional right
and so on um
do you what are the trade-offs here that
i'm that i make are there are they
severe or did you find you know this
works without severely impacting my
accuracy as such uh what's sort of the
like what do i what do i give up when i
employ this message
that's a great question so i think
there's natural trade-off would be to
say if we employ this regularization
does that
kind of hurt the performance compromise
the performance on the object detection
side right and so
uh we actually showed in the evaluation
part um in table one if i recall
correctly that this whole learning
framework actually achieves
um you know both quite effectively um it
um yeah i think it pre pretty much
preserves the map so that's on the right
most column where we show the
on the original you know pasco voc and
berkeley deep drive task
um how is that map
you know changes it's pretty much
the same or similar as the
vanilla faster cnn without adding our
uncertainty regularizer and so overall
this learning framework kind of
you know provides
an actual layer of safety net by pruning
out some of the ood object but at the
same time if it's indeed an
indistribution you know image it can
just
it can do as well
can you maybe
when when we're at the at the
experiments i did not go into that at
all in in my explanation is there things
that you want to particularly highlight
or you know what should a reader of your
paper take away from the experiments
other than
you beat all the bass lines which i
think we've come to expect a little bit
from machine learning papers
but you know what right
what should like a reader you know take
away as as sort of conclusions from your
experimental section
totally i like that question a lot and i
think part of um the ablation
uh in the paper um is i think it's quite
interesting you know going beyond table
one
we actually you know did um some of the
ablations comparing to different
uh census strategy and so i think table
two
is perhaps you know table three as well
table two is one of the
uh the interesting ones um where
we kind of try to contrast with you know
in terms of synthesize we wanted to know
you know whether this
uh gaussian based sampling is the is the
optimal one there are you know works
have done in the past for example
directly using
again to generate
uh images
um or you know you could also do
to mix up um
to have this interpolation in the pixel
space um as well
um and then they're also you know using
utilizing noise i think those are all
kind of natural
alternatives for um you know our
outlier sensitive approach
um so i think this this is a one of the
uh the ablations i personally
you know uh
quite like and and i also want to call
out the fact that
um
there is one previous paper i think they
use these proposals with the large
background probability
um as the kind of the negative samples
to regularize the model and that turns
out to be you know
also sub-optimal compared to using um
boss
um i i've also
so
you you had this decision to in the in
the very last layer uh introduce these
virtual outliers and i think in in the
video i observed something like
okay that helps if you know the out of
distribution data really looks different
in the last layer however if i have out
of distribution data but that exhibits
the same kind of low-level features as
in distribution data um that might not
be the case like in a vanilla network is
this also let's say a weakness of your
method or would you expect that your
regularizer would sort of automatically
map
these these types of outliers to
different
like would construct the latent space
such that they are different
like is it different yeah
yeah for that question perhaps you know
i can defer to your phone i think tripon
has some good answer to to that question
oh yeah uh so
yeah so actually i want to answer this
question from two perspectives so
first perspective i think you are like
mentioning some like
uh when a model actually encounters some
near in distribution od objects
so how does the feature space
functions uh to prevent the model to
predict high confidence predictions so
basically we can potentially adjust
the sampling threshold in vos to see
whether we can
create a tighter decision boundary
in order to separate those
indistribution objects and those od
objects
and in addition i think a
near-indistribution od detection is
essentially a very hard problem and
there's a couple of works
exploring this direction but they are
totally in the classification setting so
so perhaps we can explore how to combine
a voice with
those techniques in the future
so this is the first perspective i think
uh from the second perspective i i'm
mentioning you're you're like uh saying
that
uh
how can we like look at different
semantic spaces like different layers of
features actually i remember we
in the paper actually in a painting
section we have reported the od
detection performance using the
layer rather than the panoply layer for
our light synthesis and actually it
seems like the performance is not as
good as
what we have for if we use the panopto
layer as the
semantic space
for loss so basically i think the reason
is that the layer the later layers in
the neural network might be more
discriminative uh to
for classification so
uh those uh
more discriminative layers may be better
for od detection and online sensors
because those synthesized outliers
relies on the quality of those uh
estimated covariance matrix and then
those mean values for each
indistribution class so
i think
that may be the like the reason for why
we choose to use the panopto layer for
yeah it makes sense as you go earlier
and earlier the less you can probably
describe the data using sort of this
sort of a mixture model uh approach so i
think yeah it makes sense i was just i
was just wondering and even i think it's
important to remember that we're still
in high dimensions and
with being in high dimensions it means
that even if some of the features are
the same you know the moose will have
four legs and so on it will kind of look
like a dog but not fully right so you'd
still expect this
in these high dimensions to be to be
separated um
could
so maybe a bit to the the research
process right you thought of this you
thought you're going to tackle this
problem and so on uh could you maybe
share a bit of how
the process i think it's always it's
always
you know
you just see the paper at the end and
the paper is like oh wow you have some
examples here i didn't even i think show
them much in the in the video so here
you have comparisons at the bottom
everything that's green is is detected
as out of distribution which is really
nice the helicopter i think was the most
one of the most shared pictures of your
paper um
this looks really nice right uh
i think what people don't see much is
the process behind it like could you
describe it a little bit was there
was there a time when you thought this
wouldn't work or doesn't work or
uh you you know don't know how to go
further how you know how was it like to
achieve at a system or arrive at a
system that finally
works really well
oh totally i'd be happy to you know
speak on that perhaps roofing can can
add on later as well i think just like
many other research
uh process nothing works
out of the box immediately right it's i
think part of the research
the fun is really kind of going through
the the process and figuring out
you know the a lot of intermediate um
the you know obstacles and so to give
you some example right some of the
challenges i think you know really sure
fun did a lot of hard work in the
process um just when we started the the
exploration the first challenge you know
we have to
uh to overcome is
what's the right evaluation right how do
we get this
correct um evaluation benchmark because
a lot of the previous work focused on
image classification that's you know
more or less
uh well established and in order to
evaluate this new setting
uh
we have to actually
gather and clean um
all all these for example od test images
as well so that's you know some of the
uh the things you just have to kind of
uh go through and
you know during the research process and
i think on the methodology side
there are also you know the
um
the challenges as well so one of the
one thing i want to share is
there's actually one hyper parameter in
boss
which is i think called the starting
epoch
which is when you start adding this
regularizer
and so it turns out if you just train
this whole you know
entire loss with the you know object
detection plus the l uncertainty from
the start
uh things are not converging
as well so why is that because
at the beginning of the training right
the representation is not quite well
formed yet
and so therefore
estimating this
density in the latent space is not also
very reliable and not to mention the
sampling part
and so that's where we kind of got a
little bit stuck on is you know the
performance if you train from scratches
is not really as desirable
and so later on we figured out is you
know why don't we wait until the uh
representation becomes you know more
more formed so this idea of
kind of starting in a kind of later uh
training process
um helped right um you know resolve
this issue and so that's you know kind
of another example how did you but how
did you get this idea did you did you
have some indication from some metrics
that you logged or did you just you know
sit there and just try 10 different
things and this one was the one that
worked or you know i imagine you sit
there you try it and stuff doesn't
converge like it's just like well it
doesn't work what what can lead you to
come up with the correct solution
i think for this one perhaps it's more
natural because you know your
if if you think about how the method
works
it has to rely on some embedding space
that has a somewhat clear structure that
you can perform density estimation and
then sample from
and so when things you know kind of
doesn't
um work out you know one of the you know
we look at what are the kind of possible
major you know reflex that that could
happen this one would be
you know the kind of the top one we are
diagnosing into excellent um yeah i
think i think that's a that's a pretty
neat overview is there a something else
that you like to share about this um
anything that we haven't touched on
maybe anything that you want to
specifically highlight yeah i think i've
talked a lot so fun do you want to add
anything that you particularly wanted to
add on to uh i think i i don't have any
further comments sharing has covered
comprehensively about this paper um is
your your code is on online right
um so people can can go can get into it
can experiment with it um yeah i think
that's that's pretty neat uh yeah and
with that
um
thank you very much for being here and
this was very enjoyable yeah thank you
so much for having us again it's it's
been fun you know chatting about the the
work and so on thanks for inviting us
thank you
[Music]
you